are you sure about this sir no major i'm
not
this son of a [ __ ] is our only hope
he's what we like to call a problem
inmate why is that he doesn't play well
with others
[Applause]
we need you mcgruber why me you were
specifically requested
it's a suicide mission
who let the dog out
my country has invited me to die for it
and i are svp gas
queen uncle sam tells you to jump and
you go get your jumping ships classic
mcgruber
queen hello magruber
this isn't just any mission for me this
is personal he murdered my mother i'm in
thank you soldier you're gonna get us
all killed
millions of people are gonna die we're
talking about a world enter here i think
it's time to call the calvary we are the
[ __ ] cavalry
time to go make some widows get shot
smell you later vic i mean that with
every fiber of my
i will smell you later
mcgrover
[Music]
i think it might be time for a little r
and r oh yes i could use some rest and
relaxation no
the other rnr
ramming and [ __ ]
[Music]
you